diriger une commune un lourd fardeau en
49% des mers disait ne pas vouloir se
présenter à leur propre succession en
2020 si j'avais été dans une boîte
privée j'aurais rendu les clés de la
boutique depuis longtemps dans les
petites communes
le malaise dure depuis des années la
fonction de maire s'alourdit à partir
des années 70
une fois la france d'après-guerre
réparer l'état a laissé davantage de
compétences au maire leur activité
souvent bénévoles
mon rôle est de plus en plus importants
et prenant il est presque anormal de
demander un maire qui en france est
encore un bénévole or quand tous les
autres pays ils ne sont plus des
bénévoles de leur demander de suivre les
affaires comme il faudra les suivre
aujourd'hui
urbanisme voirie déchets aux écoles
culture sport état civil cette tâche
demande un minimum d'expertisé elles
sont parfois trop technique pour une
petite équipe municipale comme celle de
bruère allichamps en 1995
le hic dans les petites communes où on
n'a pas de service technique par rapport
aux grandes villes où il ya un service
technique pour les les les routes
service pour l'électricité pour pour
tout ce que vous voulez alors que nous
nous sommes le service technique et des
fois on peut arriver à faire des erreurs
le ras-le-bol monte en 2000 selon une
enquête de l'association des maires de
france 47% des maires de communes de
moins de 2000 habitants ne souhaitait
pas se représenter aux élections de 2001
c'est le cas de michel caquot à muizon
près de reims découragés par les
critiques des administrés à force
d'entendre les gens qui vous disent que
ça ne va pas on finit par se sentir
coupable de ce qui ne va pas et ça aussi
ça devient un petit peu lourd à gérer et
à force de prendre des coups mais ça
finit par faire mal et on craint les
coups suivants la démission voilà
l'issue pour des mères souvent sans
étiquette sans appareil politique le
maire il doit tout entendre il doit tout
doit se laisser faire ne pas réagir ne
pas répondre
et puis bon c'est vrai que ce qu'on vit
depuis quelques temps
les attaques les insultes les je m'y
attendais pas du tout je veux dire je
n'étais pas prête pour ça entre 2009 et
2010 7512 mer ont volontairement
démissionné dont 296 en 2017
cette année-là est marquée par l'annoncé
de la réduction des emplois aidés
précieux dans les petites communes mais
aussi la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour 80% des ménages
ressource capitale pour les mairies dans
nos petites communes on essaye de gérer
un sou leçon quoi et aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune visibilité sur sur cette réforme
et déjà on a subi rythme scolaire baisse
des dotations de l'état
en réaction au ras-le-bol des mères en
décembre dernier le parlement a adopté
une loi destinée à faciliter leurs
fonctions parmi les mesures la
revalorisation de l'indemnité de maires
de petites communes multiplié par deux
pour les villes de moins de 200
habitants
[Musique]